bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
les détracteurs de viktor orban en parle
d'un coup d'état
est ce que cette formule elle vous
semble approprié non pas du tout je
pense qu'il ya un débat très idéologique
qui s'installe au sein de l'union
européenne entre les tenants de la
société ouverte et qui aimeraient une
europe basé sur la démocratie libérale
d'inspiration anglo-saxonne houleux les
différents états ne sont que des
plateformes dans la mondialisation
ouvert à tous les flux mais les pays
d'europe centrale et orientale et la
hongrie en particulier n'a pas cette
conception de l'esn est l'état nation et
la hongrie souhaite maintenir préserver
un état-nation fort et il y a donc un
débat idéologique et l'accusation de la
hongrie de fomenter un coup d'état est
largement exagéré parce que en situation
de crise sanitaire comme en situation de
guerre tous les états sont obligés de
renforcer les pouvoirs de l'exécutif
pour être efficace et protéger la
population celle a toujours été comme ça
dans le passé dans l'histoire et
aujourd'hui c'est ce à quoi nous
assistons est donc d'ailleurs tour en
france aussi en dans l'est dans les pays
de l'ouest de l'union européenne qui
soit disant un modèle plus démocratique
qui se vante d'avoir un modèle fumel
démocratique en fait aussi prête des
mesures de confinement de fermeture des
frontières et par exemple lorsqu'on fait
une comparaison en france nous avons
aussi un confinement qui est obligatoire
et on remarque en fait dans certaines
certains territoires
ce qu'on appelle les territoires perdus
de la nation il n'y a aucun respect
très peu de respect de ces mesures est
ce qui va poser problème ensuite par la
suite pour pour sortir de cette crise
parce que il y aura peut-être un taux de
personnes contaminées plus importants
qui vont contaminer les autres personnes
qui ont respecté le confinement et ce
genre de de défaillance ne se produirait
pas en gris parce que la hongrie est un
état nation beaucoup plus uni et cela
donne cela ne date pas d'aujourd'hui de
cette crise du coronavirus la hongrie
avait déjà fermé ses frontières lors de
la crise migratoire est en fait la
hongrie a été anticipatrice des crises
qu'ils allaient affecter l'union
européenne et c'est pour ça qu'elle est
critiquée parce que la hongrie a eu le
tort d'avoir raison trop tôt
tiens et man show man et on peut aussi
comprendre que certains se posent la
question suivante gouvernement de viktor
orban est ce qu'ils ne profitent pas
justement de cette crise sanitaire pour
renforcer ses pouvoirs
alors nous allons voir à la suite de la
crise du coronavirus quelle quelle sera
la situation parce que d'après le après
ce que j'ai pu lire ces mesures
d'exception ne sont applicables que
pendant la crise la crise la pandémie
pour combattre la pandémie et ces
mesures devaient devrait être discutée
au parlement et éventuellement lever
après là qu'il crise du coronavirus mais
il est bien évident qu'un état
d'exception ne peut pas être levée si la
crise est toujours là donc effectivement
il faudra observer
quelle sera l'évolution de la situation
après la sortie de crise mais de ce que
j'ai pu en suivant le lambris comme
comme pays
au sein de l'union européenne il a quand
même un large soutien de la population
et du parlement
le haut commissariat de l'onu aux droits
de l'homme se dit inquiet neuf
organisations de défense de la presse
appelle l'union européenne a dénoncé
cette nouvelle loi
est ce que l'europe peut intervenir et
si oui dans quel cadre à alors ce sera
très difficile pour l'union européenne
d'intervenir parce que en fait là aussi
il ya un débat idéologique qui ce qui
est qui a démontré qu'en fait les
principes sur lesquels l'union
européenne étaient basés de les
frontières ouvertes la société ouverte
une société éventré qui mais qui ne qui
met les citoyens en danger devant l'état
de flux comme le cette pandémie mais
auparavant la crise migratoire les
gouvernements les peuples sont en train
de changer de mentalité de voir que cela
ne peut plus durer et donc l'union
européenne elle-même a dû s'adapter aux
décisions des états membres de fermer
les frontières de déclarer le
confinement et a fermé ses frontières
extérieures
ce qui donne raison à la hongrie et mais
il ya toujours un débat idéologique
parce que les tenants du toujours plus
d'europe
ceux qui aimeraient transférer le
pouvoir d etat nation aux instances
multilatérales évidemment veulent
prouver que les états nations dans leurs
mesures d'exception ont tort mais je
pense que éclatant on verra qui a raison
merci beaucoup
pierre-emmanuel commun je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant géopolitique
fondateur de re continent merci à vous